vamos con el problema 33 problema 33
aquí nos preguntan qué distancia viajo
julia le voy a poner aquí qué distancia
qué distancia nada más así viajo viajo
julia
william
muy bien en el enunciado 1 lo que nos
dicen es que david viajó 40 millas en 40
minutos entonces david david viajó 40
millas 40 millas en 40 minutos 40
minutos bueno esto nos dice cosas acerca
de david nos dice por ejemplo que
recorrió una milla por minuto una milla
por minuto pero este enunciado no dice
nada acerca de julia entonces no nos
sirve para obtener información acerca de
julia vamos a ver qué dice el enunciado
2 en el enunciado 2 nos dice que julia
viajó a la misma velocidad que da vida
entonces julián
julián misma misma velocidad que david
david bueno pues esto nos dice que la
velocidad de julia fue una milla por
minuto pero no nos dice nada acerca de
la distancia todavía nos falta
información verdad si tuviéramos por
ejemplo cuánto tiempo viajo julia y no
digamos viajo 10 minutos entonces
sabríamos que viajo 10 millas pero nada
más con esta información no podemos
decir nada ni siquiera juntando la con
la información de arriba va entonces
aquí le voy a poner está chiquita de que
ni si quiera o sea de que ni siquiera
sabiendo las dos al mismo tiempo podemos
contestar la pregunta entonces la
respuesta sería y la respuesta sería y
muy bien ahora vamos a pasar al problema
34 problema 34 el problema 34 nos pide
determinar el 15%
y 15% de equis o sea básicamente nos
pide determinar 0.15 por equis en el
inciso 1 nos dan la información de que
18 es el 6% de x 18 18 es pues lo voy a
escribir así es el cero es 0.06 porque x
18 es el 6% de vale bueno si tuviéramos
esta información de aquí podríamos
despejar x dividiendo entre 0.06 y ya
teniendo x podemos calcular cuánto es
0.15 por x no tenemos que hacerlo
simplemente tenemos que saber que se
puede hacer entonces esta información de
acá si sirve esta palomita quedó fea si
sirve si sirve para determinar el 15% de
x vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2 el
inciso 2 nos dice que dos tercios de x
dos tercios de x es igual a 200 a pues
misma idea aquí tenemos una ecuación en
x podemos despejar x sustituir aquí y
encontrar el 15% de x va entonces esta
de acá también es suficiente y por lo
tanto la respuesta es de cualquiera de
los dos enunciados sirve para encontrar
el 15% de x muy bien vamos al problema
35 problema 35 35 muy bien éste se ve
éste se veo interesante mira nos ponen
un número un número decimal que es 3.2
cuadrado triángulo cuadrado triángulo 6
cuadrado triángulo 6 muy bien y lo que
necesitamos determinar es cuál es el
valor de cuadrado o sea cuadrado
representa un dígito y queremos saber
qué dígito representa tenemos tres y
aquí tenemos dígitos decimales vamos a
ver qué información nos da de
información 1 nos dicen que al redondear
este número a la décima más cercana
entonces nos queda 3
ok entonces al redondear a la décima más
cercana nos queda 3.2
bueno pues tendríamos que redondear
hacia abajo verdad si este número fuera
cinco o más entonces se redondearía
hacia arriba y no nos quedaría 3.2 sino
3.3 entonces la información de que al
redondear nos queda 3.2 básicamente nos
está diciendo que cuadrado que cuadrado
es menor que 5 y como cuadrado es dígito
esto quiere decir que cuadrado es cero
uno dos tres o cuatro bam bueno eso de
ahí no es suficiente para determinar
cuadrado pero ya nos da algunas pistas
vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2 en el
inciso 2 nos dicen que al redondear a la
centésima nos queda 3.24 a esto esta
interesante 3.24 entonces este dígito de
acá para que al redondear nos quede 4
tuvo que haber sido 3 y redondeamos
hacia arriba o 4 y redondeamos hacia
abajo vale entonces eso lo que nos dice
es que cuadrado
cuadrado es igual a 3 o 4 y creo que no
podemos obtener mucha más información y
hay ejemplos para los dos casos por
ejemplo un ejemplo con cuadrado igual a
3 lo voy a poner en color morado sería
3.2 2 396 digamos donde esté aquí es
cuadrado y éste acá es triángulo al
redondear al redondear nos queda 3.24
saleh y un ejemplo donde el cuadrado
puede ser 4 sería digamos 3.244 16 aquí
al redondear redondeamos hacia abajo y
nos queda 3.24 entonces pues ni siquiera
con las dos informaciones juntas podemos
determinar el valor del cuadrado pero
bueno si lo restringimos mucho pero la
respuesta es que no que ni siquiera las
dos juntas sirven para determinar el
valor de cuadrado es decir
muy bien vamos ahora al problema 36 ese
problema lo voy a hacer en color verde
déjame bajar un poco el problema 36 en
el problema 36 nos dicen que la ganancia
de la venta de un cierto artefacto
aumenta pero no proporcionalmente
entonces la ganancia aumenta pero no
proporcionalmente no proporcionalmente
de acuerdo a la cantidad de unidades
vendidas de acuerdo a la cantidad con la
cantidad
de unidades me voy a poner así vendidas
bueno y la pregunta que nos hacen es la
pregunta es la siguiente será cierto que
la ganancia excede 4 millones ganancia
excede 4 millones
millones al vender al vender
y 380.000 unidades 380 mil unidades
bueno pues vamos a ver que nos dan de
opciones que nos dan de información el
enunciado 1 nos dice lo siguiente nos
dice que la ganancia excede 2 millones
que la ganancia excede 2 millones
millones al vender 200 mil unidades al
vender vender 200 mil doscientas mil
unidades esta información será
suficiente pues yo digo que no
o sea sabemos que la ganancia le gana 2
millones al vender esta cantidad ahora
al vender 380 mil pues quién sabe verdad
nos estamos vendiendo un poco menos del
doble pero ni siquiera sabemos que sea
proporcional entonces pues quién sabe yo
digo que estoy acá no no nos dice
realmente si la ganancia le gana a 4
millones al vender 380 mil vamos a ver
qué nos dice el inciso del inciso 2 del
inciso 2 nos dice que la ganancia excede
5 millones
exc de 5 millones millones 5 millones al
vender 350 mil vender
350.000 unidades
creo que estos de aquí sí ya nos dan más
información sí claro que sí porque ven
aquí estamos vendiendo 350 mil y ya
ganamos 5 millones acá arriba queremos
vender 380 mil unidades y nos dicen que
la ganancia aumenta si vendemos más
unidades entonces pues si el inciso 2 si
nos permite concluir si nos permite
concluir que ganamos más de 4.000.000 de
hecho ganamos más de 5 millones verdad
estamos vendiendo todavía más unidades
entonces aquí la respuesta sería b
la respuesta sería b
la respuesta sería b porque el inciso 1
no es suficiente por sí mismo pero con
el inciso 2 nada más con información del
inciso 2 podemos responder la pregunta
muy bien ya no voy a hacer otro para
tener un poco más de tiempo en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a dejarle hasta
aquí y nos vemos hasta la próxima